et avec nous maurice doyon il est
professeur d'économie à graulhet
alimentaire à l'université laval
monsieur doyon bonsoir
donc pour comprendre vraiment le dos il
a j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce qui se
fait à l'usiné de grandes baies comme
transformation du lait alors pour savoir
de quel conflit de travail s'agit
exactement
dans ma compréhension c'est que l'usiné
fait du fromage cet endroit particulier
on parle de 10 % du lait transformé par
la province est ce que d'autres usines
qui aurait pu absorber une quantité
supplémentaire de l'epo éviter le
gaspillage qu'on connaît en ce moment
c'est toujours un peu compliqué
comme vous le savez le lait quand même
le lait qui arriva de la ferme donc le
lait cru et très périssables et on est
dans une période estivale où les gens
prennent leurs vacances et on est aussi
dans une situation où il ya pénurie
d'emplois donc tout seul
normalement oui on devrait
éventuellement arriver à rediriger cela
l'eau vers d'autres usines mais c'est
quand même un gros morceau et puis les
circonstances font que malheureusement
dû jeter et est ce que ce sont les
producteurs qui doivent essayer de
trouver des solutions de rechange où il
ya comme un organisme qui essaient de
chapeauter cette situation là
bas fait le livre bien une agence de
vente obligatoire au québec qui est
kitsch et par la fédération des
producteurs de lait du québec alors que
séoul qui doit faire beaucoup d'appels
pour ici de réutiliser le laisse
certainement que la participation de
d'agropur alors l'on compte entre
l'amant de 10,6 soit des quarts de
travail ou encore de diriger seul l
ovaire un produit que l'on peut
transformer qu'on peut conserver plus
longtemps bon évidemment ces solutions
de rechange là elles n'ont pas suffi la
parce que le lait n'a pas été
complètement de rediriger on a parlé de
deux millions de lei de litres de lait
qui ont été jetées seul hélas qui est
jeté par les producteurs est ce que ce
sont les finalement les producteurs qui
sont les victimes collatérales de ce
conflit de travail dares qui sont payés
pour le lait qu'ils jettent comme ça
du lait dont ils doivent se débarrasser
finalement oui effectivement on doit
s'en débarrasser parce qu'il ya juste
plus de d'endroits où le maître le le 6
cl ou dans les usines bat son plein donc
du coup on est plus adroit donc on doit
le jeter et il faut comprendre que les
producteurs ou québec comme chez eux
selon une agence de vente obligatoire
donc ils sont payés un cri ou le prix
pondérés alors chaque producteur donc
envoie son lait et donc quelqu'un qui le
ramassage des oeufs ont notamment lieu
et on prend un échantillon également ce
que les posteurs son pays selon les
composantes laitière alors lorsqu'on
doit jeter du lait comme c'est le cas
présentement alors il ya eu chez le
postier jeter son lait il ya eu une
mesure on april échantillons pour savoir
quelle est la composante et on va faire
comme si cela allait dans le coup mais
le pool voyais plus petits ils sont
passés par le vent à être payés donc
c'est collective
tant de l'idu québec qui vont subir le
coup alors comme si je distribue sa
couleur sur l'ensemble des petites
heures c'est c'est nettement moins ça
fait moins mal à chacun d'y poster que
si c'était un seul ou deux ou trop pro
stock succès 100% de la personne bien
entendu donc c'est un impact collecter
les producteurs pour les consommateurs
maintenant si on retire 10% de du lait
qu'on offre au québec qui est transformé
potentiellement au fromage à l' usine de
grandes baies est ce qu'on risque de
faire face à des manques sur des
tablettes
bas juste pour nos penderies 10% ont
produit environ 70 millions de litres
par semaine en clans dans le sol et deux
millions de litres et ça devrait aller
en diminuant à mesure qu'on trouve des
solutions mais si jamais on devait jeter
des millions de litres de lait l'eau à
tous les deux trois jours ça pourrait
finir par avoir un impact mais ça serait
plutôt étonnant là au moment où on se
parle à court terme il devrait pas y
avoir des packs ou les consommateurs il
ya une marge de manoeuvre et a terminé
1er de sa marge de manoeuvre l'eau avec
son million d'électeurs qui n'ont pas lu
un petit peu plus haut encore 100
centres mais est ce que ray quand même
des façons d'éviter que des millions de
litres de lait comme ça soit acheter est
ce que c'est une façon de jeu c'est pour
moi d'avoir de l'entreposage
supplémentaire est con on réfléchit à
ses options là
c'est une bonne question je ne sais pas
si
c'est toujours la question de qui va
subir le coût d'une installation qui va
servir peut-être une fois ou deux ans
peut-être chemin qui est en même temps
comprenez qu à mesure qu'on devient de
plus en plus concentré et c'est normal
pour baisser les coûts les entreprises
tendent de plus en plus gros donc on a
de moins en moins de joueurs dans des
usines de plus en plus important et ça
ça nous met à risque et un buggy dans
une usine young revient sur ben arrive
ce qui arrive présentement on est vécu
la même chose dans le poulet
précédemment le dans la nuit à coups
dans le
dos très important transformateur de
coûts liés au québec alors notre risque
va augmenter avec le temps à mesure
qu'on connaît notre institut se
concentre alors est ce qu'il faudrait
envisager des solutions comme ça mais la
question demeure qui va
assurer le coût de ce cette capacité
supplémentaire là et est ce que le coup
propositions des princes
200 millions pour économiser 5 millions
ou deux ans je suis un alcoolique ou
d'efforts et faire les calculs et
j'imagine qu'elle illustre il le fait ce
calcul maurice doyon vous êtes
professeur d'économie agroalimentaire à
l'université la base vous remercier
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i regardez